you have Steph who's a shooter Giannis
is dominant Katie is an unguardable
scorer what are you in the rap game what
do you do the best me I do me the best I
would say that I'm
uh like a LeBron I dropped my first solo
album when I was 14 and that's the Same
album I'm talking about that went
platinum and I've been doing this at
this pace of higher ever since just like
him so that you remember Tom Brady was
every year was still even though he was
winning the Super Bowl and all it still
was is this a year he going to retire we
don't even say that but we don't want
you to retire yeah we want you to stay
forever that's what I'm saying so when
people ask me like when the call the Six
coming out I like God damn it that's six
of them and they still want it